just one question what if you miss I
won't
so I'm a Halo fan always have been so I
knew getting hands-on with the Master
Chief collection would mean nostalgia
lifts all up in my grill when three or
four three kicked off the preview with a
never-before-seen remastered
pre-rendered CGI cinematic from halo 2
anniversary campaign I got chills
those same hair-raising spine-tingling
chills you get from like a badass song
it took me back to 2004 fifteen year old
me sneaking out on a school night
waiting in line for my pre-ordered metal
cased halo 2 and then rushing home only
to find mom waiting for me at the front
door busted I forgot I did that 10 years
ago it was a nice little flashback come
November I look forward to tapping into
that excitement again I'm doing that
trick baby legendary campaign halo 1 2 4
I got to briefly spaz out on that
instant halo 2 graphics which from
original to remastered with awesome but
I'm doing co-op first with my childhood
best friend like we've always done for
every halo release taken back on a couch
reminiscing those days where that was
all we did and that's what I really miss
sleepovers on my garage system link 8 on
8 Blood Gulch hour-long CTF matches all
night we were just a bunch of riled up
kids cursing so loud that my neighbors
would complain there were no mics to
hide behind when you talk smack on your
flawless triple kill
you didn't just feel the blood boil in
the other room you realize friendships
wrecked stay for the day tell one time
my friend lost it so bad and someone's
12 year old brother for dropping a game
winning flag a kid ran out crying I'll
admit that was messed up but we were
animals back then those were the most
gut-wrenching gaming moments I've ever
experienced for the first time in 10
years I'm trying it out again and my
first immediate impression playing the
multiplayer and Master Chief collection
was totally weird first minute in I'm
thinking whoa I forgot how to play halo
2
charging up on that first finishing
melee move and I switch my grenade to
the plasma oh yeah
melee was the B but it was awkward at
first but by the second match it was
coming back it was cool dusting off and
reconnecting those buried halo to brain
synapses but what really hit me the
hardest was realizing how halo 2
multiplayer was just so simple it was
just about the maps weapons
who's got sniper someone go for shadi
they have rockets now those are lines I
haven't heard in a long long time and
that was all that mattered
no fine-tuning your loadout with perps
and between matches but focusing on a
care package or timing some sort of
charge up Power Move everyone started
out on the same playing field regardless
of what rank you were just headshots and
whatever power weapon you managed to
snag first that was it okay fine
Plus cloak and / shield but come on you
are a piece if you always went for that
the sixth remastered maps do get minor
changes like the Mongoose getting a
front-mounted gun and a few creative
environmental gimmicks like the ice
falling down a lockout sniper perch for
the time shield and the center of
ascension but nothing really that
excessive and three for three even plays
it safe bringing back all of the
original halo maps as well as these
remastered ones I mean you can play the
original halo combat Evolved online no
Halo fan is left out on this so yeah I'm
stuffed it is a series I've really cared
about growing up get times have changed
halo 1 and 2 for me we're all about
playing with close friends and gang
rowdy shooters nowadays are all about
grinding for that gear there's nothing
wrong with the simplicity of Halo I love
it
and it's too early to make assumptions
but I'm curious to see what people will
think about digging up these old FPS
roots and finding out for themselves if
it still tastes the same as it did a
decade ago